[Music]
in a February Gallup poll 72% of
Americans viewed Russia unfavorably this
is the highest negative rating in three
decades Americans clearly believe that
Russia tried to interfere in the 2016 US
election in January and March Quinnipiac
University surveys around 70 percent of
registered voters said that it did
people want the Russia investigation to
continue and most people feel confident
that Special Counsel Robert Muller will
conduct a fair investigation in three
identically worded questions asked by
pew from November through early March
between 55 and 61% felt confident
looking forward Americans are concerned
about the November 2018 elections in a
new Marist Poll fifty-one percent said
that it was likely that there would be
Russian interference in them 41 percent
said it was not very or not likely at
all and they want President Trump to do
more in the March Quinnipiac University
poll 61% of registered voters said that
the Trump administration should be doing
more to protect the elections from
Russian interference what do you think
about the Russia investigation let us
know in your comments also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI